una situación sanitaria preocupante en
los dos territorios franceses de
ultramar guadalupe y martinica desde
parís
231 enfermeros y 70 bomberos despegaron
rumbo a las islas en apoyo frente a un
repunte inédito de los contagios de kobe
19 en estos momentos en guadalupe y en
martinica en particular nos enfrentamos
a una situación dramática que reclama la
solidaridad incondicional de toda la
nación un confinamiento estricto fue
decretado en martinica y el mismo
destino le espera a guadalupe donde el
ministro francés de ultramar inició una
visita del martes
desgraciadamente vamos a tener que
reforzar este confinamiento porque
realmente necesitamos frenar la epidemia
aún más rápido no lo hacemos porque
queramos pero es evidente que debemos
proteger a la población
el personal médico debe verse desbordado
nosotros los médicos y los enfermeros
todos los cuidadores no queremos tener
que elegir entre los pacientes por eso
luchamos día a día para conseguir abrir
el mayor número de camas posibles pero
desgraciadamente el tamaño de la ola es
tal que no podemos acoger a todos los
pacientes que necesitan cuidados de
reanimación
sólo el 22% de la población recibió una
primera dosis en martinica donde la
variante delta representa el 40 por
ciento de los contagios en guadalupe
esta variante representa el 88% de los
contagios
es en los territorios de ultramar donde
se plantea hoy un escenario urgente
si hay que demostrar que la vacunación
es el medio más eficaz para responder a
esta variante del delta manos no
desgraciadamente se demuestra cruelmente
en las antillas
que las autoridades esperan que el
confinamiento ayude a frenar la
propagación del virus